hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well at the beginning
of book 4 of Plato's Republic
Adam antis comes in with a challenge for
Socrates Socrates has been slowly
elaborating this ideal city and it's not
the purely ideal city we all have to
remind ourself it's it's sort of a
second-best ideal city as we see in book
2 be that as it may it is a pretty
organized place by comparison to most
political communities of Plato's time
and indeed even of our own time a very
rationally organized community and it
has these people that Plato calls the
Guardians there's the Guardians who
actually run the city itself they're the
rulers of the city and then there are
the auxiliaries or the lesser guardians
and this is the soldier class the people
who have a great deal of what Plato
calls through most its translators the
passionate or spirited element of the
soul it's a part that it was we see
later in book 4 that gets angry and in
which courage resides and those two
classes effectively run and protect the
city then we have this vast assemblage
of all sorts of people doing other jobs
ranging from farmers to shoemakers to
the
you know sale from city to city bringing
in goods that can't be produced there
you know everything else under the Sun
that you can think of those are the
third class of craftspeople as they
typically get called and within the city
the way it's arranged the rulers rule
the auxiliaries protect the craftspeople
produce and they all stay out of each
other's business as much as possible
they do also earn a living but for the
most part the guardians are not earning
what we would normally consider to be a
great living and so this is where Adam
Ant assist challenge comes in he says
what is your defense Socrates if anyone
objects that you're not making these
people very happy and that through their
own fault and here he says something
kind of interesting he says the city
belongs to them meaning they're the
rulers of the city but he talks about it
in such a way as like it's their city
they own it the way that a lot of people
will indeed think of their government
positions as if I'm the one who owns
this or that happens in the military as
well and in the university so he says
the city really belongs to them but they
get no enjoyment out of it as ordinary
people do by doing things of this sort
owning lands building fine houses
providing them a suitable furniture and
winning the favor of the gods by private
sacrifices and entertaining guests and
enjoying to those possessions which you
now spoke of gold silver all that is
customary for those who are expecting to
be happy so you know the ruling class
are not getting the perks they're not
getting distinctive benefits that you
would think they deserve they're doing
extra work they're in charge of things
they're taking on greater
responsibilities why are they not
getting a bigger piece of the pie why
instead does Socrates say well we'll let
the money-making thing be for the
craftspeople
the rulers are actually going to live a
rather austere life
why is that going on this is stemming
from a certain conception of how
politics ought to go that Adam antis is
representing here and Socrates has a
broad answer to this that has a lot of
other aspects to it but first let's look
at the challenge Socrates says you know
what you're right
as a matter of fact let me make the
picture even more clear they serve four
board wages meaning that basically what
their wages are they get to eat they get
food they get put up somewhere right and
it's not a fancy place it ain't the the
Ritz Hotel it's not some special room in
the barracks or anything like that no
they they get the stuff just like
everybody else
and there's no possibility of advancing
further in terms of these perks or
benefits he says they don't even receive
pay in addition to their food as others
do so they can't take a journey on their
own account if they wish or make
presents to their mistresses or spend
money in other directions according to
their desires their sole reward is to
get to serve and now if you say that I
think a lot of people would be like look
you know before you were talking about
being a guardian and that was like
that's the job for me
I like being in charge and then when you
ask people about it they're like and you
say okay you're gonna be in charge but
you're not going to get any benefits and
as a matter of fact the ordinary people
are gonna have it better materially than
you are they'll be like I don't think I
want to serve anymore as a matter of
fact you give it to somebody else well
what's it that a sign of they're not
really that interested in service for
its own sake they're interested in the
perks that come with it and that's a
common mindset isn't it now Socrates
says the goal for all of this is to
produce the greatest happiness of the
city as a whole
as a totality it doesn't mean that the
happiness of the citizens isn't
important there's a lot of
interpretations of Plato's values of
totalitarian and
doesn't count at all that's all nonsense
you know
if you read the Republic carefully you
see that Socrates is actually providing
good reasons to think that the people in
the city would in fact be happy they
won't be happy necessarily in the same
respect that we typically or the ancient
Greeks typically framed it in terms of
having lots of possessions and social
pull and getting to be you know a big
person or something like that but they
will have happiness as a whole and we'll
look at what that consists in in just a
moment so Socrates says listen here's
one of the implications of this we are
not just interested in the happiness of
one class namely that of the rulers you
could say that the city belongs to them
but it's really belonging in the sense
more of a responsibility or stewardship
than it is ownership they're not owners
of the city as a matter of fact you
can't actually say that there is an
owner of the city except the city as a
whole
everybody is supposed to be taken care
of everybody's happiness counts it's not
quite the same thing as utilitarianism
where we would do some numerical
calculation or anything like that
although a plate it was quite fun of
mathematics as we all know but it's not
going to be the focus on the happiness
of the ruling class we have to think
about what produces happiness overall
and it's fair game to say that within a
city like this we don't have to
automatically assume mistaken
conceptions of what happiness consists
in so that's not a restriction for us
and Socrates engages here in
consideration of what the function of
the classes are so you know he goes on
he says we need to mold the model of a
happy state we're not isolating a small
class in it and postulating their
happiness if we think about it in terms
of you know like a statue for example
we were colouring it by the way ancient
Greek statues as we now know were
generally painted not just the bare
marble as we often see in museums so he
says that if somebody applied the most
beautiful pigments to the most beautiful
parts of the image that would be the
eyes right and he says for the most part
they're not painted with purple but with
black and now why is this important
purple is this dye that's difficult to
get and very expensive and so as a
pigment it would be you know quite hard
to come by but you don't paint the eyes
purple because eyes don't belong purpley
you know at least the the pupil of it
needs to be black that you can do with
you know ash right it's quite easy to
make black pigment so he goes on and he
says don't expect us quaint friend to
paint the eyes so fine they will not be
like eyes at all nor the other purse but
observe whether by assigning which is
proper to each we render the whole
beautiful kalos ordered fine noble those
are all translations of that so he says
in the present case you must not require
us to attach the Guardians a happiness
which will make them anything but
Guardians happiness that makes them no
longer the class they are is not really
going to be good for them and it's not
gonna be good for the city what would
that look like well think about the
happiness of the imagined lottery winner
who now has millions of dollars at their
disposal and they go around they buy up
a whole bunch of stuff and you know they
maybe go into work and give their boss
the big fu you know the finger or
something like that and they reward the
few co-workers who are nice and they
punish the co-workers who are mean and
all this sort of stuff that is not
really compatible with the function of a
guardian what is the function of the
Guardian to use their intelligence to to
arrange the city properly to deal with
crises and new situations to do planning
all that sort of stuff and
people do in don't do indeed enjoy that
sort of thing don't they there are some
people not everybody does not everybody
likes to balance their accounts not
everybody likes to plan for the future
but there are some and those are the
people that you want in charge those are
the people you want the Guardian class
similarly those are the lesser guardians
or auxiliaries you don't want them like
sitting around playing video games all
day eating chips getting fat and you
know taking it easy you want them out in
the field practicing their craft
whatever it happens to be could be
firefighters could be EMTs I think they
would fit into that class as well could
be the soldiers could be the police
could be whoever the people who respond
to dangerous situations and look out for
the good of the city in that way you
want them doing that function and
similarly even the craftspeople Socrates
goes on he talks about for example we
could clothe the farmers in robes of
state and deck them with gold and build
them cultivate the soil at their
pleasure and make the Potters recline on
couches from left to right before the
fire drinking toasts feasting with their
wheel alongside to Potter when they're
so disposed and we can make all the
others happy in the same fashion so that
the entire city would might be happy but
or just not to do this why why is that a
bad idea because the farmer will not be
a farmer nor the Potter a Potter nor any
of the types that constitute a state
keep its form he says you know there's
also a consideration of importance here
if cobblers deteriorate and are spoiled
and pretend to be the workmen that they
are not no great danger to estate but if
the guardians are corrupted by their
desire to make a buck and lord it over
other people then you've got real
problems you're not going to have a
happy city because things are going to
be screwed up likewise if the soldiers
don't want to go out and engage the
enemy and protect the city and remember
ancient Greece was a patchwork of little
city-states that did in fact have to
defend themselves against other Greeks
well then you're not gonna have a happy
city look for long because it's not
going to be a city for law so another
thing that he says it's really quite
interesting each class gets a share of
happiness a share of good living a share
of being fulfilled that is appropriate
to its nature or that its nature admits
of so the idea is that you've got these
different kinds of people right you got
the intellectual class the warrior class
or soldier class the the defenders and
then everybody else who are supposed to
be productive workers right not just lay
about drones doing nothing and each of
these types of people can be made happy
it by certain things so what what
actually makes them happy and here we
have some considerations that are that
are quite interesting some of these are
in the text some of these we have to
think about a little bit more but I
think it can be supported by the text so
one thing that that Socrates talks about
is appropriate wealth now the guardians
are not gonna have any wealth but what
about the ordinary people the
craftspeople so he says one of the
things that Guardians have to attend to
is that people aren't too rich and that
they aren't too poor why he says
consider whether these are the causes
that corrupt other craftspeople and
spoil them wealth and poverty so you
don't think about poverty how does that
spoil the craftsperson well the
craftsperson doesn't have the means to
attend to his or her craft and support
themselves that's kind of an easy one to
understand how does wealth screw them up
how does wealth corrupt the craftsperson
well he says that they're going to
become idle and negligent that is kind
of funny when you think about it is a
little bit of a digression here the
reluctance to help out the working poor
in a lot of cases you know we're going
to give them a handout and that's gonna
ruin their work ethic you know thought
of Socrates and Plato didn't think that
was an issue they thought that you know
the ones who are rich are the ones who
have a garbage work ethic
don't do anything because they're rich
right taking somebody and elevating them
from a situation of precarity
economically into being solidly middle
class back then Socrates thought that's
the best thing that you can do for
craftspeople to allow them to work their
job with security not to have to worry
about am I going to lose my health
coverage when I lose my job is my boss
you know going to run the company into
the ground or anything like that
the idea is you do your job and you get
some wealth in in return and you enjoy
the things that wealth provides and
that's good
distinctive activities each class is
made happy if they're actually well
brought up if they've got their
priorities right by doing the things
that they have a talent for and enjoy
doing so that the carpenter in this
ideal city it's not like people who
don't want to do carpentry become
carpenters again you know the the pic
shion's of Plato's Republic as being
this totalitarian Republic where your
jobs are handed out to you like you know
the Communist Party used to do back in
the day total nonsense
everyone in Plato's Republic does the
job that they are most suited for the
thing that they have the greatest
affinity for the thing where they can
get some you know enjoyment and
satisfaction out of engaging that sort
of stuff if you like medicine you're a
doctor provided you can actually like
you know do the thinking involved if not
maybe you'll be an orderly maybe you'll
be somebody else if you're really good
at cleaning things you'll be a janitor
but you're going to get paid well and
you're not gonna have people looking
down on you because doing janitorial
work is actually quite important if
you're well suited to being a
firefighter we put you right over there
so doing the things that actually make
you happy is part of being happy sounds
like a no-brainer doesn't it but that's
that's the way that Plato is depicting
it I think there's a third way in which
people within the city are made happy
that isn't talked about right here but
you could think about it as running
throughout the entire structure of the
work and that is being able to live in a
good city being able to on one hand look
at your environment and your neighbors
and and think oh these are decent people
I'm happy to live here they're not going
to steal my stuff or treat me badly or
get me caught in some sort of stupid
bidding war of keeping up with the
Joneses conspicuous consumption anything
like that and on the other hand you can
take pride civic pride in being part of
this you know larger hole that runs well
and that looks out for everybody's
happiness
so in Plato's Republic and this is an
ideal conception of course but in
Plato's Republic as Plato depicts that
as Socrates is narrating it the citizens
and the city as a whole
are both made happy by the way things
are arranged and the rulers have to
attend all these things but presumably
understanding this would be part of the
education that the rulers themselves
receive
you